[Music]  thomas ernest muller  ex-cop  convicted of murder and a burglary gone  wrong  apex is quite simple  that hunters  you are the prey  what's the price if i kill all the  hunters  win and i can guarantee your freedom  [Music]  my good hunter welcome sign me a real  challenge  who the hell is that  do we get a refund if we kill this guy  within an hour  you're good kid i'm better than good i'm  bacon and eggs on sunday morning  malone has defied death more times than  most navy seals  simply put  the universe just can't seem to kill him  man like that never should have come to  a place like this  let's remind malone who is the hunter  and who is the prey  i win that's all i do  that won't be happening  bring me the head of thomas malone  you're only logical choices to beg  beg me to let you live  this ain't that kind of fight even  better  [Music]  you